we've already seen many examples of
infinite series but what's exciting
about we're about to do in this video is
we're going to use infinite series to
define a function and the most common
one that you will see in your
mathematical careers is the power series
this is the power series and I'm about
to write a general case of the power
series so I could imagine a function f
of X being defined as the infinite sum
so going from N equals zero to infinity
of a sub n so a sub n is just going to
be the coefficient on each term times
our variable X minus some constant C you
can almost imagine this is shifting our
function to the nth power so if I were
to expand this out I have my first terms
coefficient a sub zero times X minus C
to the 0th power plus a sub one times X
minus C to the first power this one of
course will simplify to just a sub zero
this would simplify to a sub one times X
minus C plus a sub two times X minus C
squared and I could just keep going on
and on and on now when you see this you
might say well our geometric series
don't look like a special case of a
power series if our common ratio was an
X instead of an R in that case or if our
if our if we if our common ratio was a
variable I guess I could say and you
would be right that absolutely would be
the case so a geometric series so let's
just think about defining a function in
terms of a geometric series and of
course we don't have to use X all the
time as the independent variable but
this is kind of the most difficult
convention I guess we could also use R
as in the dependent variable if we want
it as well but imagine let's imagine a
function G of X we could have G of R if
we wanted but let's do G of X is equal
to the sum from N equals 0 to infinity
of a times X to the N so this is kind of
a this is kind of a typical geometric
series here and what's the difference
between this and this well the
difference is is here for every term
we're going to have the same coefficient
a while over here we have a sub n we're
multiplying by a different thing every
time up here we're multiplying by the
same
anything over here and in this case this
particular geometric series I just made
instead of having X minus C to the end
we have just X to the end so you could
say well this is a special case when C
is equal to 0 and we can expand it out
this is a times X to the 0 which is just
going to be a plus a times X to the
first plus a times x squared and we just
go on and on and on forever
now what's exciting about this is we
know we know under what we know that
this under certain conditions this will
actually give us a finite value this
will actually converge this will
actually I guess may give us a sensible
answer so under what conditions does
that happen well this converges is if
each of these terms gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and each of these
terms get smaller and smaller smaller if
the absolute value of our common ratio
the absolute value of our common ratio
is less than 1 so let me write that down
so this converges converges if the
absolute value of our common ratio is
less than 1 or another way of thinking
about it this is another way of saying
this is another way of saying is that X
is in the interval between it's less
than 1 and it is greater than negative 1
and this term right over here now X is a
variable X can vary between those values
we're defined a function in terms of X
we call this the interval of convergence
in interval interval of convergence and
so we know that if X is in this interval
this is going to give us a finite sum 1
we know what that finite sum is it's
going to be it's going to be equal to if
it converges so if it converges this is
going to be equal to our first term
which is just a this simplifies to a
right over here over 1 minus our common
ratio
what's our common ratio our common ratio
in this example is X going from one term
to the next we're just multiplying by X
we're just multiplying by X right over
there now this is pretty neat because
we're going to be able to use this fact
to put more traditionally defined
functions into this form
and then try to expand them out using a
geometric series and this whole idea of
using power series or in the special
case geometric series to represent
functions has all sorts of applications
in engineering and finance using a
finite number of terms of these of these
series you can kind of approximate the
functions in a in a way that's simpler
for the human brain to understand or
maybe a simpler way to manipulate in
some way but what's interesting here is
instead of just going from the sum to
instead of going from this expanded out
version to this this kind of finite
value we're now going to start being
able to take something in this form and
expand it out into a geometric series
but we have to be careful to make sure
that we're only doing it over the
interval of convergence this is only
going to be true over the interval of
convergence
now one other term you might see in your
mathematical career is radius radius of
convergence convergence and this is how
far up to what value but not including
this value so if as long as our as long
as our x value strays no stays less than
a certain amount from our C value then
this thing will converge now in this
case our C value is zero so our art so
we could ask ourselves a question of
what is how as long as X stays within
some value of zero this thing is going
to converge well you see it right over
here as long as X stays within one of
zero so as long as it can get it can't
go all the way to one but as long as it
stays less than one or as long as it
stays greater than negative one so it
can strain no more or I guess it should
it has to it can it can straight
anything less than one away from zero
either in the positive direction or the
negative direction then this thing will
still converge so we could say that our
radius of convergence our radius of
convergence is equal to 1 another way to
think about it our interval of
convergence we're going from negative 1
to 1 not including those two boundaries
so our interval is 2 so our radius of
convergence is half of that as long as
we stay within 1 of 0 R as long as X
stay
within one of 0 and that's the same
thing as saying this right over here
this series is going to converge